hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to completing the mission
the latest game about henry stickman the
guy from
escaping the prison and stealing the
diamond and infiltrating the airship
and escaping the complex really fun
games with lots of left if you haven't
seen him i'll put links in the
description below but in order to get to
the new one
with a hundred and sixty something
endings
i had to play through all the other ones
so you're gonna see uh a quick
cuts of me playing through that some old
bits that i've had before but if you
want the full context
watch those videos because this this
game this new game with all its new
endings and lots of new laughs
is dependent on the endings that you get
from those games so check that out and
then you'll see what's happening and
then we're gonna move on
so here we go this is the henry sickman
[Music]
collection
hell yeah
this is it this is it this is the one hi
hello
we're here oh oh
what
it does matter it matters
it matters so much you do have to do all
the other ones okay we'll start with
this one
and then we'll see where it goes from
there because this new
level has about 168 different
endings or failures whatever
so let's see what this is all about oh
oh wow
oh wow
wow
[Music]
i know it's been a long ride but we're
almost there you've heard of the top act
clan right
they have a secret base out here i'm
hoping they might let us join up with
them now that we're on the run
hmm should be right around the what hang
on
yes sir we found them they took me back
here just like you said
i'm on the way send in the entire squad
it seems like some other government is
here they are fighting with the torped
don't worry about them focus on henry
and the kill
ah uh rope regi
that's not what well
well that's new uh yeah all right
rope wings bye
see you around try and get up to the two
enemies
ow yeah i'm fine you all right
oh hey how you doing i'm right here bro
nice
now where's the other one how you guys
are too good
crap corruptic corruptic i don't like
corrupt tick
oh no what have i done
oh okay
[Laughter]
let's try and get up to them right okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god it's a nightmare
uh disc time machine
absolutely every time i'm going too far
back
i one month into your training this is
only the beginning it will be
harder you can't be twins you boys will
never be fit for combat duty
i will personally see to it that you are
discharged
let's try and get up to
all right you good all right let's get
going
uh okay
once we get to the top of this tower
we'll cross the bridge and be on the
rocket why do we want to be on the
rocket
that clan will let us join ah
dad they are here on the bridge open
fire
roger date okay well
oh my god grapple oh jesus
ow henry will remember that
oh grab my hand
take my hand grab it grab my hand
that's so stupid all right whatever all
right what do we got
uh block
quickly hold it you're not talking no no
no
we're here to join you we're wanted just
like all of you uh-huh
wait you're the guy that stole our ruby
uh
you have some skills oh okay can you
join
as long as you return the ruby sure oh
those two belong to me
you're coming with us
oh this is charles i'm following up on
that disturbance we saw at the bridge
yeah it turns out the top bad leaders
are here
wait is that henry henry come on help me
take down the top
oh what do we do
what do we do
[Music]
what do we do oh none
listen babe it's you and me against the
world
it's us
[Music]
holy crap probably not the best idea to
stab a knife into a spaceship
oh my god
that's a strong knife whoa oh
uh can we breathe no the answer is
no okay how about the wall yeah we trust
the wall the wall is definitely the
people that we trust in this scenario
we're giving up we're going to the wall
see you guys
you two will never see the light of day
again and this is
my choice this is the choice we had
oh oh god
why did we choose that if you can't
leave him
why did we choose the government
all right i got a plan we got to
big play baby big play
oh
what did i do yeah nice work both of you
this is charles reporting i got a couple
of friends here with me you're never
gonna guess who they are
never gonna guess well and if it isn't
le2 we've had you on our watch list for
a while
thanks for your help here today wow i
think we could trust you after last time
i guess we owe you one well now that you
mention
it we do have kind of a criminal history
problem
yeah i figured that was coming i suppose
you've earned a pardon
wow hey the peepee path
okay cool the peepee path oh hell yeah
then what does tophat clan do
thanks they're dead they're
dead well not dead okay
now get strapped in we're about to blast
off
yeah by about you mean now we're not
strapped in
oh hey
hey now you've taken everything from me
my reputation is ruined okay
okay he's dead
he's dead he's dead
oh
[Music]
everyone i'd like to welcome our new
members
they really showed their gust there when
it counted
also they promised to return the ruby
hmm
i shan't be doing that
i shan't all right let's work our way
backwards
grab my head
ah damn it catch
rude all right there was one more in
here disguise kit
you'll never see it coming
hey brother hey
all right fair enough all right what
else we got three fails here
oh i just happened to pick the right one
[Music]
hilarious hilarious okay oh
wait
all right thank you oh wow
oh damn i have to go through get all the
other combinations
oh fascinating fascinating okay
so i've got a job to do i have to go
back and i have to go through everything
of these
and get to all those endings so i can
get to all of these endings because it
matters
it does so i'm going to do that we're
going back
i'll see you in a bit let me just uh
help you get across that gap
charles all right here i come charles
[Music]
[Laughter]
buddy
jesus christ all right man okay cool
good
ah spook him hello mr spider
[Music]
wait wait all right this is gonna take a
lot longer than i thought it was
i got to get like all of the endings in
both of these games and i remember when
i did that
it took like uh it took it took could
probably take a couple hours so i'm
going to come back
i'm not gonna i like it there's some
funny stuff here but obviously if you
want to see it go see the other videos
that i've done
of these games i am going to have to
play through this on my own
rick okay and with that
i now have i'm recording right yes i am
recording
i now have all of the endings from the
previous two games it didn't take as
long as i thought it would
let's go let's go to different
combinations
first yeah let's go different
combinations
first just to get some variety and then
we'll go back and trace over everything
hello government ah yes
yes yes i remember that
yes i remember that and i remember
leaving ellie behind
the players of hosting most recent
message
this is a code broadcast the remnants of
a top hat clan have been seen mobilizing
near the dogo bogo jungle rumors are
they are attempting to launch an
orbital satellite of some kind
unconfirmed reports are telling us
they are shipping their assets by train
to this base in the jungle
these assets include all treasures and
artifacts they have stolen throughout
the years
now these treasures are worth quite a
lot of money so we gotta make sure
fair henry very fair
this is checkpoint inspection team five
we are all clear
box i suppose we should hop in
how did we lose one i think you should
throw it in the cat
just to be safe
i love it i love that i love that
i love that i love it
mannequin oh check out this crazy
coat rack oh look at me i'm a little hat
holder person
can i take your hat i wonder what's out
the window
[Laughter]
it's not that god i i've missed this
game
i miss this sense of humor i love it so
much
window oh hey that worked
shockingly that worked i don't know why
that worked but shockingly that worked
oh god free transfer
well hey
easy all right trains here let's get
everybody oh
collectibles oh no oh no not
collectibles i don't think trucks can
make that incline
although a lot of things in this game
aren't really cohesive with physics
the suck pack the suck pack
the the suck pack
[Music]
i love the suck pack
car wow
no way the suck worked
i can't believe that the suck actually
did it
all right good stuff everyone today's
the day
why is it empty in here
damn i gotta go back i almost i almost
aced that
almost aced that completely all right go
back to the beginning prop
well i suppose we should hop in yeah
it's about time
is that bush always there i'm not sure
i'll give it the test
[Laughter]
excuse me uh i'm saving that seat for my
friend
hello hello oh hey there you are
yeah no this guy just took me a seat
okay uh this one i i apparently nailed
it and
i figured pinchers
where what
oh oh no
rollercoaster tycoon reference i love it
window
good stuff good stuff displace these on
any object they will turn into a leaf
transport the biggest things was these
leaf oops oh no
i mean technically infinicube
oh oh
all right relentless bounty hunter we're
gonna go with presumed dead
this is so cool i love it i love the
dedication to the combinations of
different endings who'd have thought
like i i that's really clever
and you have to package it all together
in one so everyone can have everything
yes we have all the goods loaded up on
the train uh
i don't want to be on caravan duty oh
it's not so bad
you get to sit on the train and hang out
are we meant to protect all our stolen
valuables
all the money all that oh yes i suppose
that's true
we have all of our money in one cart i
suppose that's pretty important to
protect
well i guess we better get going i watch
where you're going
oh henry
oh yeah he's got a tank i forgot about
that he got a tank
oh fire baby yep
the oh
join i'm here
no no no wait no wait no no
no no don't shoot me plow
[Laughter]
i just love how fast everything is ready
how fast everything is god damn i gotta
go back
to go back to the
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh
hey hey oh
gosh agility oh [ __ ]
no agility agility
we can't follow nice the tunnel do i
have to do everything myself
maybe
well all right
so you're the one causing all the
trouble me
i don't expect to have to use this i
don't even know what that is
oh
oh item
mirror
oh my god
oh hey that actually worked uh
all right then we
can't get in why don't we go out the
back
i see
[Laughter]
huh this is pretty bad
uh hell yeah i did it
oh boy hey
that's awesome way to go
me hey you know what boss can't find it
anywhere
nice little nest egg
that's nice all right i gotta go back
mercy hey listen he's not taking me
seriously
[Music]
ow act
bribe hey i'll give you your money
all right okay
am i able to move or something bite him
ah yoch
[Music]
i think maybe that heart's supposed to
be in the middle but i'm not sure wait
wait what did that joke say
seeing the conductor riddle with you
with bullets it fills you with
determination
and bullets man my land
oh hey this seems to be working oddly
nice oh wait no yeah i'm going into the
oh okay
all right watching you make choices is
such a train wreck well no need to be
rude
by air i don't know how oh
okay all right goddamn that's awesome
okay we're gonna go rapidly promoted
executive and
the betrayed interesting interesting
interesting
oh yeah the drama
hello
hey hey easy easy
you were gone for a bit i was able to
bring you back to life
i specialize in military grade
augmentations
i was forced to replace spine and lift
arm a
sum of damage you sustained was beyond
repairing
you had run in with topet clander
i've encountered them before you see
you're still healing
they went south if you are wondering
about 10 hours ago
oh wow you're learning so quickly
aren't you proud all right bye
thanks for everything i guess
i'm thinking once we arrive we should be
able to
henry take him out
blade form
sick
damn this is epic
time to finish you off
[Music]
that was awesome that was awesome
why was that so awesome
absorb it
oh god
oh man
ah that's pretty good
[Music]
all right yeah well whatever baseball
bat
something about peanut butter jelly oh
my god
i'm so amazing uh oh
uh i guess why type move i don't know
what that means
[Music]
okay
oh
nice awesome
i really thought the absorb was gonna do
it out of here
there what are you going to do
i'm going to drop you like you dropped
me
you don't have to do that i do
[Music]
anyone available there's an attacker in
the cockpit
ow well that's not fair
staple uh sure
convenient so that's it then
you're just gonna leave me here to go
down with the ship
ow looks like we'll be sharing this last
ride together
i'm captivated
well you got us
what is it worth it
i'm captivated i mean i don't know why
this is such a silly story but i'm
captivated he did it
he won after all this time
he won stickman
has done it
[Music]
has risen above and beyond
nice uh but i didn't get everything
because i did it too awesomely
spirit form i don't know
[Music]
[Music]
hey
me
seo
[Music]
well there you have it
gun form never bring a knife to a
gunfight am i right
wow are those liquid bullets
oh lasers even better
ow all right i'm going to airship you
uh what's the plan here buddy what's the
plan what's the plan what's the plan
here buddy what's the plan
all right
all right man cool well that was one of
each
so now we get to go through and pick the
different varieties of what it could be
okay let's start back at the top and go
thief
ghost in me god is there like a
storyline to each of these
i got the ruby i did not rescue
ellie good evening
the topic plan continues to remain
untouched by the governments of the
world
okay their rocket launched earlier this
week has placed the space station in a
stable orbit around the globe
okay the station has plenty of room to
store all the clans members as well as
the stolen valuables
okay among these valuables is the
priceless norwegian emerald chambers
just last year
the top action are also thought to be
the ones responsible for the theft of
the romanian ruby
and the tunisian diamond the orbital
station allows the topper clan to easily
raid any place on earth
hey chief our satellites have picked up
a hostile object oh no is it the
government
did they send a destroyer after us
no well just shoot it down
[Music]
light speed oh wait wait wait
i love it less i love it less i love it
less
oh that was an aileron roll yeah you're
right
you're right you're right it was
mosquito mode
sure
oh yeah we completely missed and they're
uh
they're on the ship now completely
missed we spent so much money on that
[Music]
uh-huh am i supposed to remember this
because i won't weapon oxygen
big vent something something oh my god
blow me
great great kaboom teleporter always
works
always works
no it all what no it oh
oh wow
uh
well
smash it
oh my god
how about we just open it oh wow
it was that easy
oh hi oh no you don't hey reg
yeah i found that intruder excellent
work i knew i could count on you
hang on a minute this is the guy that
stole our ruby
now he's trying to steal our emerald guy
you better take care of him with
pleasure
fire supreme dominance now okay
charging up supreme dominance for you
super henry
jesus
oh
nice ow
it's me
all right
[Music]
i made it i nailed that
i only had like two failures the whole
time
breaking news the topic orbital station
has been completely destroyed
we are unsure of the exact details at
the moment
several escape pods have been seen
entering the atmosphere
the topic chief's escape pod was found
but there is nobody inside
we're here government forces state they
do not know whether he survived he did
not
if you had to know unless you call me
the top at chief which i am now in
another timeline i love that that one is
that one was a had a lot of choice all
right let me go back to the beginning
real quick
i think if i just run out of time
[Music]
yeah of course all right uh i nailed it
because i was like of course the
teleporter would be the one
because it's never worked leap
[Music]
[Laughter]
pole vault
[Music]
[Laughter]
rip
rocket
[Music]
bridge
i love it i love it i love it so much
okay eject it
see it all right
one sec
ah i don't know what game that's
referencing
emerald take that
oh all right then that was all of those
wait there was
wait there was something else here load
save what is this
for you
i get it i get it i get it i get it i
get it i love this
okay uh pure-blooded thief we did
presumed dead did we do presumed dead
was that what we just did no we did
ghost inmate okay let's do presumed dead
there's so many of these there's so many
there's so many there's so many
hello yeah can i speak to the chief
please
not available well look i was just
wondering if the rocket plan was still
in action
maybe you know the rocket plan firing up
that space station into orbit
yeah the one where we can just sit
around
no you know luxurious lounges
plenty of room great view of earth far
enough away from any meddling
governments
yeah still happening then yeah
right we're leaving from that jungle
base then right
what relax mate no one's going to be
listening in here
you really think someone's going to try
and steal an entire rocket
you must be mental right yeah
mentally smart
yeah that's what i meant
[Music]
oh all right well it's too late now oh
my spine
limbo oh
[Laughter]
i'll stop hi hello oh yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
who is that can we stop him please
boy but it's so hot
look you're not allowed to change heads
all right now drop it
oh there's something there oh whoops oh
keep your eyes peeled and stop him if
you spot him uh
did i do it oh i did it oh okay
close the main door uh all right
hey wait i need to go in there
hey wait i need to go in there
hey wait i need to go in there
oh crap he's riding straight up
what is this guy doing trying to steal
our rocket
we'll take care of this thanks ryden man
what oy chief
got a clear shot here yes go ahead
[Music]
hammer ow
okay all right
hammer
okay
hammer oh
wow
emergency launch protocol activated
he's hijacking the rocket right head man
where are you three i thought we had
like two i thought we had a few more
on my watch
thank goodness i have a giant harp
[Music]
a shot nailing it
nailing it oh
well that worked i can't believe that
worked
wow my rocket now
damn welcome to stickman space resort
welcome built out of a former top at
base yes
luxury board have reformed and now work
as crew members
that remained on earth were arrested as
you know resort is run by the man
himself henry stickman that's me
why did he steal a criminal clan's
rocket and decide to turn it into a
resort
because he's a genius but hey you
wouldn't be here if that didn't happen
it wouldn't be there here here there you
wouldn't be here there
hi henry stickman that's me uh i can't
believe
just all time pace i love that it's so
hard
[Laughter]
all right now drop it ramp
oh wait no hang on
why are you doing it what's next uh what
did it drill
yeah take my drill
all right stages
oh
well i mean technically i guess yeah i'm
not gonna question the physics i'm not
gonna question the physics of anything
in here
all right that was everything in the
pure-blooded thief now for the
government-supported private
investigator convict allies
convict alex yes
hi hello hi yes
arrested hi hello
yes partners in crime
sure this is where he's going to pick us
up ah there he is
you said you did some work with him in
the past or something
if you trust him then so do i you should
hey henry
nice to see you again who's your friend
i don't know ellie
well nice to meet you any friend of
henry's is a friend of mine
so uh i was able to swing by and pick
you guys up
but well you remember the captain yeah
he
had to sanction this pickup in return
we're gonna need your assistance again
oh the top bats oh
i hope that's all right well it is the
least we could do
he is helping us out that is reasonable
yeah that's reasonable fill you in on
the details when we get into the air
all right so what's left of the top egg
land is set up uh
some sort of secret base out in the
jungle it's like they're planning on
launching uh some kind of space station
into orbit
it's pretty if they pull this off so we
gotta make sure that they don't do that
talk to the general and he said he's
pulling out all our main forces
he said that henry and i made a good
team last time so i trust that we can
pull it off
oh kerry and i make a pretty good team
too don't count me out
all right fair enough make a great squad
squad three of us we'll have no problems
no problems leading the mission
yeah yeah completing the mission
all right we're there we're here i don't
think i can get any closer without
getting shot down no worries we can get
there from here
how are we dropping boys
jetpacks
love it nailed it weirdly
smooth that's how genius i am what's the
plan
the rocket will be launching very soon
please get on board immediately
i will not hesitate to leave you behind
oh sounds like they're about to take off
you guys should get over there right
away
i'll be down to help as soon as i can
build nice
this is great
yes
oh
all right yeah i died i'm i'm aware of
that
barrel
love it
well
[Music]
[Laughter]
combo time
[Laughter]
hahaha
[Laughter]
oh god damn it oh
god
[Laughter]
i'm fine i'm fine hannah
funny story this cannon was actually
built to fire humans it's kind of weird
you don't need to explain anything to me
hey we made it
taking off we yeah got a little bit of a
situation
what do you mean fusion
nice nice who will challenge me
i'll take care of this you think just
cause you fused you're a match for me
don't make me laugh enough waiting
[Music]
[Applause]
around
oh okay well that didn't work out
is that yamcha says
diversion
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it i
love it i love it
[Music]
i love it i love it sorted out
baby sorted out all good
the rocket's launching we gotta do
something
we gotta do something quick quick
what do you mean like you're gonna jump
out and smash it with your head
no no with my helicopter what do you
guys think i'm ready hold on i don't
really understand what's not to
understand it's simple i fly the
helicopter into the window
but how does that help
i don't really think you get it henry
you get it
guess i'm now right then uh i think it's
a little bit
out of range now
[Laughter]
god damn it i wanted to see it henry's
plan
oh yeah yeah henry actually spoke a word
yeah
oh yeah oh yeah that's a great idea
all right you guys do your thing i'll be
ready what is our thing who's that
it's me
always a good idea all right then let's
bail
what did we do oh oh okay we're fine
that shouldn't have worked
ah what a move i can't believe we did it
where'd you end up sending the rocket
anyway
is it the complex oh it's the wall
nice that was a lot of fun feel free to
call us if you got any more jobs to do
together
right henry
yeah that is pretty good but now it's
time to not do so good wings
wow
again a game reference i'm not familiar
with
i don't know what that is aerosols
we got some delinquents on the window
the control tower
i'll take care of it yeah i was just
about to close up
oh ah fortnite
parachute which is the normal way okay
and we're dead
all right no guns okay
swap
oh wow yeah oh yeah
throw
uh-huh good throw
swap climb down and run
that makes sense
uh-huh
uh still running i can just pick you up
oh you're staying committed to your
choice i can respect
ah fair enough
oh
uh oh
all right ellie's flan all right guys
listen up i got a plan
all right and i will overload the engine
room causing an explosion
sounds good we'll need you to wait
outside the auxiliary exhaust
by the forward left booster we'll only
have about 20 seconds to get out before
it blows
fair all right i'll be ready hurry
fancy engine ship engine that's not how
ships what
wait i just all right i'm in position i
don't see you guys though
oh god this is so good it's such a good
stuff it's so good it's so good
it's just so good okay i've done that
one already
now we gotta go presume dead god it's so
good
it's so goddamn good that's the thing
it's
so good it's just so funny
it's just so fun you want to see
everything god you know
like this was an inspiration for me
doing uh like
uh a heist with markiplier and stuff
just like i love
just fun choose your own adventures
they're so fun
we're playing it is the fun
henry henry hi
ah man the top back plan has been
causing a bunch of problems for me
lately
yeah yeah ever since they got that
orbital station set up they've been
super strong
now that i think about it you and i made
a pretty good team in the past
oh yeah baby oh yeah
personal okay well what do you say you
want to help me
take him out for good oh yeah awesome
all right follow me i have a way we can
get into space i love
this i trust this
secret government prototype what do you
think
there it is there it is how do you want
me to bring you in
oh this is so exciting it's just like
last time just like last time
trashball me put on the spacesuit and
hide in this ball of trash uh
what it's a good idea trust me i trust
you
of course she should still be able to
help you get inside from here though
yeah absolutely
charles you got it
before it explodes all right
all right the door is jammed this is the
only way through good thing we're sticks
lift it we're so strong hack it i think
i can hack this panel to get the door to
open
[Music]
yeah i have no idea what i'm doing all
right fair enough man
vent this vent leads
[Music]
okay top hat top hat
oh the one he just went in
fair enough luxury oh
oh give me two more got room for two
okay you don't want to shoot guns on a
spaceship it cracked and broken
well that was intense ah can't wait to
go home huh
hi oh hey no
charles charles
[Music]
[Music]
pretty good plan i could say it was the
[Music]
greatest
general the top at station's been
destroyed
excellent news what's wrong
[Music]
no no
oh my god make me laugh dammit
all right i'll just swing by i guess
drop you off yeah drop me off you're
alive sale
do it hey chief government ship
approaching oh my god okay so blow them
up already
[Music]
hey it actually worked well okay all
right
fair enough air cannon weird but this
air bubble is going to keep you
breathing so you get to the side wings
all right
all right it's also really sturdy so you
don't have to worry about it popping on
you
unfortunately it doesn't move very fast
don't worry i'll keep you company until
you get there shouldn't be a problem
what kind of movies you like
[Laughter]
i love charles i love charles so much
all right later
laser me this might
fire a super make laser shot right next
to you
it'll make a hole you can climb through
and get inside you know
we're under attack maximize the shields
oh oh that was accurate though i gotta
admit get that button there on your
helmet
go ahead and press that it's a knife
that's so hot it can cut through any
material
no no you dropped it didn't you
oh well i mean i didn't know he's not
dead he's not
dead he's not he's not dead
he's not dead he's not
dead all right this is the last charles
one i think
oh man i i love charles so much
god it loads i i love this game so much
i love it so much
this is it's so good it's so good
my god it's so good hey general
hey
this station into orbit they'll be
impossible for us to take down
weird yeah i know you don't know us
anything henry but we could really use
your help on this
bizarre with this one and you'd be we'd
be owning you a big
big old favor you and charlie have
worked well together in the past so we
figured you'd be the perfect man for
this operation
yeah what do you say henry you can count
on us general
they can count on us potatoes so don't
let us down boys we won't let you down
we won't down you won't be lit
hey i know uh we just started and all
but uh i
think i'm getting targeted by a santa a
sam turret deal with that
you got it baby i'm gonna draw it
is this actually gonna work only clouds
i don't really know what you to have did
but trick
the rocket will be launching very soon
oh god
immediately heavy to leave you by
with hand oh invisible bridge me
all righty i've uh teleported that
platform in there for you
yeah go ahead and just uh make your way
across then
you across trapeze me
oh man it looks like every member of the
topic
um if you get to the engine room you can
shut down the engine
and then uh the rocket won't be able to
take off
and then they'll all be stuck in here so
i'll cause a distraction while you make
a run for it to the engine room got it
got it
uh subsonic wave whatever that means
[Music]
okay
of course of course of course
[Laughter]
oh god oh my god oh my god this rocket
has an internal engine room
it probably like manages the electronics
or something i don't know i'm not a
rocket doctor
anyways do you think buddy i will
do my red herring
it seems like we're having some problems
with the engine the
engine of them
god i love it shouldn't we be helping
with the engine
no they're sending something from the
storage nice
is definitely gonna buy you some extra
time now here's what i'm thinking
if you can get up to the cockpit
controller rocket
disable it and lock everyone inside then
i'll call in the reinforcements and
we'll make these arrests easily easily
pretty good plan right pretty good
bug juice so we'll turn the user into
the bug
i'm a bug now
how do i turn back oh
all right swapper instantly swap places
with anyone just point the rod the
person you'd like to spot places with
it's that easy i use this every day it's
great
thanks gadget gabe
cockpit is coming up you should be able
to gain complete control of the rocket
from there
all right it's the engine why
hold it right there well this is the
same predicament i was in a little bit
ago
i know you you're the guy that arrested
the airship division and now you're here
to bring down the rest of us
yeah okay henry are you in trouble if
you're in trouble say flank steak
no wait it's in trouble say nothing but
someone yeah i still can't tell
oh actually i can see you from here yeah
it looks pretty bad
let the loner rock i got your back buddy
[Music]
how am i nailing this how am i nailing
these
how am i doing this how am i doing this
[Laughter]
how am i nailing that bath how did i do
that
oh my god
it's so good so goddamn good
henry nice work man
nice this is uh this is every last
remaining member getting hauled off
fine work indeed boys
indeed yeah you both into special
cobradops agents
what henry's not even enlisted well he
is now
unless he doesn't want it you'll be
running a lot more missions together
with charlie yes
yes yes
yes okay i nailed that i
nailed that that's one of the longest
ones and i nailed it i
nailed that all right stomp it
take that taking one of these oh
oh 91 of 34.
panel take that
so it kind of looks like the sam
turret's shooting all of its missiles
but that can't be right i just wanted to
make sure
cupcake
oh yeah i forgot i was supposed to be
saving him
trapeze worked i can't remember which
worked jet pack
jet pod me oh
yep that's the one that didn't work tv
wow hey guys come check this out
someone's streaming tv out here
[Laughter]
oh off it
oh my god
yeah okay yeah yeah painting portal
uh-oh
where
[Laughter]
all right fair enough sleep them one
sleepy boy coming right up
one sleepy boy through mountains of
paperwork to find it
and now of course
[Laughter]
sniper sniper that spots out bad guys so
i'll just take him out from here don't
worry this
there's zero chance that i'll hit you
with this
oh i'm losing control oh boy
[Laughter]
okay oh my god oh
wow oh my god i love that
okay so we hit a hundred
endings of this game now
i am actually going to stop this episode
here
because uh the developer of henry
stickman puffballs uh he's actually
selling this one on steam
and i don't want to reveal all of the
endings because
this is a delight it's this this whole
experience is fantastic
if you look at all you get from this you
get remastered versions of
everything which all have their own
endings anyway and i bet there's some
secrets that have been added into these
ones here
but also there's still 64
more endings to see here in escaping or
completing the mission
which is phenomenal and there's so many
achievements to get and there's the
secret collectibles in the game
so i highly encourage you guys to go
check out this game and support the
developer who has been making this
for years years and years years and
years
now i'm probably gonna finish this up at
a later date
maybe like a week from now or a little
more but i just want you guys
for those who want to get the full
experience play this for yourself
i highly recommend you go check out this
game link's in the description on steam
i'm not sponsored in any way by this i
just want to support puffballs for
making this
and please do like absolutely please do
this is something worth your time
i think it's definitely worth the
purchase there's secret achievements
there's all kinds of stuff all over the
place i don't even know what half of
these are what the hell
there's so many secrets okay so link is
in the description i will finish this
at a later date but i encourage you
right now to go check it out on steam
and get it for yourself and play it it
is
fun it is just so fun it's all the magic
like of a choose your own adventure but
just with the this special humor that i
i truly adore that just makes me laugh
so hard every time
and i'm sure there's plenty of other
stuff in here that's going to make you
laugh as well
so thank you everybody so much for
watching remember check out the link in
the description below leave a like if
you did
and let me know if you want to see the
rest of this at a later date
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you